What about the disciplines on campus?
It seemed to be primarily devoted
to the activist cause like,
because my view is,
or my fear is that we've subsidized,
um,
the activist disciplines,
let's say women's studies
as a good example,
but we could say social work and then
the faculties of education now as well.
I think they're in the same,
in the same bin.
Let's,
let's,
let's put it that way.
The women's studies programs
in particular there,
their express goal expressed on their
websites is to produce social justice,
radical left leaning activists.
And so like for awhile,
one of the things I proposed in Canada
was that the conservatives in particular
cut the university funding by 25% so
that the universities would have to sort
themselves out.
But then that was,
it was a provocative claim obviously.
But then I thought,
well,
that's not a good idea because it opens
up the door to political interference in
the academy.
And that's bad.
That's exactly,
that's right.
That's right.
But the academy's done a very bad job
of policing itself methodologically.
And we have these disciplines.
Women's studies I think
is a prime example.
And that's been very much criticized in
Canada by Janice Fia Manco who used to
be,
yeah,
she is.
And she's,
she that she's not under natural mill.
You when she's doing such things,
you know,
she's,
she's a brave and tough person and she's
gone after the women's studies types on
methodological grounds particularly.
But,
but there are people who are working
full time at doing nothing but producing
the kind of polar.
So what do you have any lots about?
Yes,
I do.
I think so.
Um,
here I,
I teach in the business school here and
I teach a course called professional
responsibility and I teach my
students about their fiduciary duties,
their duties to their employers,
the duties that we have to each other.
Um,
and fiduciary duty refers to a very,
a very high standard of care.
If you're managing someone's money,
you know,
you,
you really have to be committed
to doing what's in their interest,
not in your interest.
And I think we need that concept.
In the academy we have,
I'm not sure if she would call fiduciary
duties or just professional duties,
but I think we have two primary
professional duties that we must never,
never be tray one.
The most important one in our role
as scholars is our duty to the truth.
We must never say things that we think
are false or allow people to stay,
things that we think are false because
we're afraid if we challenge them,
we'll get in trouble.
So we have a fiduciary duty
to the truth and political,
ideological commitments clearly warp us,
they make us do things,
they make us,
they push us.
So we've got a hole.
We've got to recognize that if we
let our systems get out of whack,
we are betraying the truth.
Where systemically do you want to?
If we ever went systemic,
truth isn't problem.
We are systemically betraying the
truth in many of our disciplines.
So I think we need an awareness of that
and we need to hold ourself to a higher
standard.
They ended our role as teachers.
We have,
and we really can call
it a fiduciary duty.
These are people's children
who are sent to us to educate,
um,
to enlarge their minds,
to teach them skills.
If we were to use them
for our sexual pleasure,
it's obviously a horrific crime.
But what is it if we use them
for ideological purposes,
if we say you've given me
your children to educate,
I'm waging a political battle.
I'm going to try to get your statements,
tools,
it's tools that is horrific,
that is unacceptable.
We are violating our duties.
So I think we need it.
Right.
But the,
the response to that,
especially from the postmodernist
types is that that's all the ribs.
There's only ideologic.
Yeah.
Perfect.
So back to original question.
Um,
are there problem departments?
Absolutely.
So I wanted to put forth these two
commitments to truth and to educating,
not indoctrinating.
Yeah.
And universities that embrace these
highest goals like the University of
Chicago,
I think is the best candidate
will probably find that
they need to do something
about department that don't
live up to those goals.
Other universities.
And I think Brown is leading
the way on this one so far.
I mean earlier in 2015 the president had
all kinds of statements about brown is
committed to social justice,
a fundamental bedrock
commitment to social justice.
She said.
So if some universities choose to
devote themselves to social justice,
that's fine.
Just be upfront about it.
Say So.
So students will know if you
want social justice training,
you go to Brown.
But if you want to actually be trained
to find the truth to do research,
you go to Chicago and I think we're going
to see people flooding to Chicago and
schools like it.
So what I'm hoping,
what I'm hoping that's
the mechanism there.
If they,
if they make the,
if they make their statements public that
the choice of the students will be to
go to the universities that
hold the principles that
you just described over the
other ones.
It will be a marketplace choice.
Exactly.
That's right.
So that's why I said when I talked
about the emperor's new clothes,
we have a situation,
we have a gigantic market failure in
which our top universities are offering a
product that most consumers don't want.
And so my prediction is that Chicago
is going to see a huge surge of
applications this year.
And if that's true,
um,
I think other universities are going to,
they're going to take notice.
So I'm hoping that we'll see a schism
in the American academy between those
universities that stand up and say,
this is madness.
We are committed to providing a platform.
We don't discriminate based
on viewpoint and politics.
That's the Chicago way.
And those that say,
no,
we're about social justice.
Come here and we will train you to
fight for social justice and against the
right.
So if,
if people have clear choices,
then I think we're going
to see a big change.
And that's why I'm optimistic,
because I think we're going to see that.